>> YES IT WAS.
>> WE REVEALED THE ALL-STAR
STARTERS.
THIS WILL BE A LOT OF FUN THIS
EVENING AS WELL.
>> WHY?
HE IS LEAVING?
>> NO.
WE HAVE THE BRIEFCASE.
>> THE BRIEFCASE AGAIN?
>> YEAH.
>> WHERE IS THE LADY THAT
BROUGHT IT IN?
>> WE ENJOYED THAT.
>> SO, WHILE THE STARTERS ARE
VOTED ON BY THE FANS, PLAYERS
AND MEDIA, COACHES VOTE FOR THE
RESERVES.
THEY VOTE IN THEIR OWN
CONFERENCE.
CAN'T VOTE FOR YOUR OWN GUYS.
BUT BEFORE WE OPEN THE
BRIEFCASE, LET'S BRING THE
NEWEST MEMBER OF OUR CREW IN,
DRAYMOND GREEN JOINS US FROM SAN
FRANCISCO.
DRAYMOND, THREE-TIME ALL-STAR.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A VERY
EXCITING NIGHT FOR THE 14 GUYS
THAT HAVE THEIR NAMES CALLED
TONIGHT, MAN.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS WEEK AND WAITING FROM
STARTERS TO RESERVE IS ALWAYS A
LONG TIME.
I AM EXCITED TO FIND OUT WHO THE
ALL-STAR RESERVES ARE TONIGHT.
HOPEFULLY THIS WON'T BE LIKE A
DRAFT PROCESS FOR ME WHERE I AM
SITTING HERE, SITTING HERE AND I
AM NOT A RESERVE.
>> I AM PRETTY SURE WE GOT YOU
ON TV.
YOU MADE THE TEAM.
>> NOT NECESSARILY.
>> IT IS A SEALED BOX.
>> THERE IS NO WAY HE IS NOT
GOING TO BE ON IT.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE HAD HIM ON TV.
>> A TURNER EMPLOYEE NOW.
>> IF YOU DON'T MAKE THE TEAM,
QUIT ON THE SPOT.
THAT WILL BE GOOD TV.
>> LET'S GO EASTERN FIRST.
>> WE ARE GOING WEST FIRST.
AND THEY ARE ALL IN INDIVIDUAL
ENVELOPES.
>> YES.
>> HERE IS OUR FIRST WESTERN
CONFERENCE.
>> DRAYMOND GREEN.
I GUARANTEE.
>> DEVIN BOOKER.
>> YES.
>> NICE.
>> WELL-DESERVED.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> THIRD ALL-STAR SELECTION IN
HIS SEVENTH SEASON, GIVING THE
SUNS 25 A GAME.
THAT IS NUMBER 13 IN THE LEAGUE.
FIVE REBOUNDS, FOUR ASSISTS, 15
GAMES OF AT LEAST 30.
HE HAD 48 AGAINST SAN ANTONIO.
SO DEVIN BOOKER IS AN ALL-STAR.
>> ARE THESE IN ANY PARTICULAR
ORDER?
>> NO PARTICULAR ORDER.
>> OPEN THE ENVELOPES.
>> NOT ONLY THAT BUT YOU GET TO
ANNOUNCE THE SECOND.
>> ERNIE, I LOVE YOU ERNIE.
THAT IS WHY ERNIE IS BETTER THAN
YOU.
>> TEACHER'S PET.
>> DOES IT TASTE LIKE CHICKEN?
>> FROM THE DALLAS MAVERICKS,
LUKA DONCIC.
>> THERE YOU GO.
REALLY, REALLY SOLID.
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> FOURTH STRAIGHT ALL-STAR
APPEARANCE IN HIS FOURTH SEASON.
TIED FOR EIGHTH WITH STEPH CURRY
IN POINTS PER GAME.
HE HAS 26 A NIGHT, NINE
REBOUNDS, FIFTH IN THE LEAGUE IN
ASSISTS.
HE HAS GOT SEVEN TRIPLE-DOUBLES,
NINE GAMES OF AT LEAST 30
POINTS.
HE OF COURSE THE 2019 ROOKIE OF
THE YEAR.
SO LUKA DONCIC AND DEVIN BOOKER
SO FAR.
SHAQ.
>> ERNIE, WHERE IS MY ENVELOPE?
DO I GET TO OPEN ONE?
>> I WISH THERE WAS A TIMOTHY
WEAH -- WE COULD DO THAT.
>> FROM THE UTAH JAZZ, RUDY
GOBERT.
>> RUDY MAKING HIS THIRD
STRAIGHT ALL-STAR APPEARANCE IN
HIS NINTH SEASON.
16 POINTS A GAME.
LEADS THE LEAGUE IN REBOUNDS
WITH 15.
HE HAD 22 GAMES WITH AT LEAST 15
REBOUNDS, SIX GAMES OF AT LEAST
20 FOR THE REIGNING DEFENSIVE
PLAYER OF THE YEAR.
RUDY GOBERT IS ON THERE WITH
LUKA DONCIC AND DEVIN BOOKER.
WE SHOULD HAND IT TO CHUCKSTER.
>> NO.
>> HAND ME THAT.
>> MY NEW BFF FROM THE GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS, DRAYMOND GREEN.
>> HEY NOW.
>> DRAYMOND.
ALL RIGHT.
>> THAT IS AMAZING.
>> THIS WILL BE HIS FOURTH
APPEARANCE.
EIGHT POINTS, EIGHT REBOUNDS.
>> I KNOW WE NEVER BECAME BFF
KENNY.
>> GOT A TRIPLE-DOUBLE THIS YEAR
FOR THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS
WITH A RECORD OF 39-13 HAVE THE
SECOND-BEST RECORD IN THE
WESTERN CONFERENCE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> WELL DESERVED.
>> THANK YOU.
PEOPLE AROUND HERE YELLING.
THEY MUST BE ON A TAPE DELAY.
>> EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> PLEASE STOP IT, KENNY.
>> THEY ARE OPENING THE
ENVELOPES ON TV.
NOBODY KNOWS.
>> YOU THINK WE WOULD HAVE HAD
HIM ON IF HE WOULD NOT MAKE THE
TEAM?
>> GOOD POINT, CHUCK.
>> CHUCK, I DON'T THINK THEY
KNEW.
I HAD TO COME ON AND PERFORM MY
DUTIES, MAN.
>> DRE, WE ARE NOT THAT CRUEL
AROUND HERE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
ARE WE READY FOR NUMBER FIVE?
>> YES.
>> FROM THE UTAH JAZZ, DONOVAN
MITCHELL.
>> OKAY.
>> DONOVAN MITCHELL.
HIS THIRD ALL-STAR SELECTION.
THE THIRD STRAIGHT IN HIS FIFTH
SEASON.
25 POINTS A GAME.
NUMBER 12 IN THE LEAGUE.
FOUR REBOUNDS, FIVE ASSISTS,
SHOOTING 45%.
13 GAMES OF AT LEAST 30.
FOR THE 2018 SLAM DUNK CHAMPION.
>> WOW.
THIS IS WHERE IT GETS
INTERESTING.
>> DONOVAN MITCHELL GETS IN.
>> THOSE GUYS WERE LOCKS.
>> NOT NECESSARILY.
>> LET'S GET TO THE LAST TWO
ENVELOPES.
KENNY, WOULD YOU BE SO KIND.
>> YOU ARE GOING TO GIVE ME
ANOTHER ONE?
>> YEAH.
>> THIS IS A SHOCKER RIGHT HERE.
NO IT IS NOT.
FROM THE PHOENIX SUNS, CHRIS
PAUL.
>> 12-TIME ALL-STAR.
>> CP3.
>> THIRD STRAIGHT IN HIS 17th
SEASON.
>> THAT WAS A LOCK TOO.
>> LEAGUE LEADER IN ASSISTS, 15
POINTS A GAME, FOUR REBOUNDS.
FOUR GAMES WITH AT LEAST 13
ASSISTS INCLUDING THE
SEASON-HIGH OF 19 AGAINST THE
SPURS.
SO CHRIS PAUL JOINS HIS TEAMMATE
DEVIN BOOKER FROM THE PHOENIX
SUNS.
>> WOW.
NOW THIS IS GOING TO BE
INTERESTING.
>> THIS IS THE FINAL WESTERN
CONFERENCE RESERVE.
>> THANK YOU, SIR.
>> CERTAINLY.
>> FROM THE MINNESOTA
TIMBERWOLVES.
>> STOP NOW, CHUCKSTER.
>> JUST GUESSING.
>> DEJOUNTE MURRAY.
>> SHAQ.
>> FROM THE MINNESOTA
TIMBERWOLVES KARL-ANTHONY TOWNS.
>> THIRD TIME HE HAS BEEN AN
ALL-STAR IN HIS SEVENTH SEASON.
FIRST TIME SINCE 2019.
NINE REBOUNDS, FOUR ASSISTS.
TEN GAMES OF AT LEAST 30 POINTS
FOR THE 26-25 MINNESOT